Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the, well,
my table's not round.
My table is a rectangle.
My table is a big oval.
I've got an ellipse.
This is my dining room table
that I'm seated at in my own home.
I'm in a corner of my living room
at a table that I actually,
I actually got upset with my
wife about buying this table
because she got a nice table
that you have to screw together
in order to--
As opposed to what?
Well, like a folding table.
Okay.
It was a table that she got for a party
that has since been canceled
because of the virus.
Yes.
My son's 16th birthday.
And because she can't
just have a folding table
like everyone else, she's gotta
have a pretty, wooden table
that you have have to put together,
I was like, "Why do we have this?
"We have to put it together."
But now I am so thankful
to my beautiful wife
and my smart wife, my wife
who had so much foresight,
Jessie.
She's not watching.
She's probably not listening.
Well, she's taking a shower right now
if I must be honest about this.
You must be honest.
Because right before we started recording
I said, "Okay, guys,
I'm starting to record,"
and no one responded, she said,
"Well, I'm taking a shower."
And then my fifth-grade
son had just continued to,
he's talking to his
classmates, he's learning.
They're learning.
He's doin' school.
We are in a totally, I mean,
this is the first thing
that has been completely
altered because of the virus
for us in terms of content.
This is the first-ever Ear Biscuits
that we are performing remotely,
separate from each other.
Performing.
Performing?
I don't consider, that's
interesting but effective.
I feel like I'm sayin'
weird words 'cause I'm not--
You think that you're performing?
I'm not in my normal environment.
I would've just said, "Doing."
This is the first Ear
Biscuit that we're doing.
I don't mean performing
in a performance sense,
like in an entertainment sense.
I mean performing like
in a surgical sense,
because I'm gonna be honest,
I'm a bit stressed out
because, I mean we've got,
it's just me doin' everything on my end.
I don't know if you've got assistance.
I don't think you do.
No, I don't--
If you do I'm gonna be angry.
I tried to get my
children to help and they,
they did not respond.
I'm performing a freaking
technical feat here
that, you know, I'm freakin' rusty.
Thank goodness we've been doing the vlogs.
I at least know how to work our camera,
and now it's like, I had
to dust off my GarageBand
to figure out how to record
myself, and then we got this--
And just so everyone will know--
I got an iPad video-chatting with you.
Yeah, just to give you an
idea of how this is set up,
if you're that kind of
person who's interested.
Well first of all, let me just say
that something will go
wrong with this recording.
It is just destined.
There is destined to be an
error somewhere in the process,
and you're probably gonna
be somewhat frustrated.
Hopefully not, but--
I'm pretty shocked
we're three minutes in
and nothin's gone wrong
except for my use of the word performance.
And I also thought that this would be
a simpler process to set up.
I was like, oh, okay,
we're gonna do this thing
where we're gonna do like a split screen.
We'll talk about how
we're trying to figure out
the same kinda deal for GMM,
but essentially we've got the camera
that we normally record the
vlogs with recording video.
We've got audio going
directly into a computer.
We both have these Blue Yeti mics.
This one I've had forever
and Link had to get that one.
So this is like one of our
first mics that we ever bought
as a company.
Yeah, I actually saw a clip
of when we went back to Harnett Central,
we went back to our high school,
I think we shot a week's
worth of episodes from
Miss, I can't remember whose room,
Ms. Soule's room, our old French class.
Yeah.
Yeah, we had that microphone.
So, man.
So those mics are going
directly into our laptops
which are recording the
audio on GarageBand,
but then in order to
be able to communicate
with each other at the same time,
we are on a Google Chat that's on an iPad
that we are looking at.
So I'm now looking at
Link, who's looking at me--
If other Mythical team members want to
log into the chat they can
watch this as it's happening.
Here's what we want to do
today, we want to process,
we want to bring you up to speed
on what our process has been
as we've settled into staying at home
and coming to grips with
what this virus means
for us and what it means for our world,
and also the world in general.
I just wanna process
that with my friend here.
I mean, there's also
this thing that's like
getting past the fact that
we're communicating on screens.
This is the new normal, a lot
of communicating on screens.
We'll get into all that.
Well, 'cause I will say,
again, we're recording
this a few days before
the audio goes live, a week
and a half or so before,
almost two weeks before it would go live,
a video on YouTube, so a lot
may have changed by then,
but currently where
we're at in California,
we are under a stay-at-home order
so it is technically illegal
at this point for us
to conduct our business
in the way that we typically would,
i.e. going into the studio.
Now, I think we're--
We wanna protect ourselves,
we wanna protect other people,
we wanna do the right thing--
Yeah, we're not doing
it just because it's--
We're trying to figure that out.
We're not not doing it
just because it's illegal.
We actually, and it's interesting,
at this point in the
conversation nationwide
there's very different perspectives.
There's people who are like,
"Oh, this is a complete overreaction,"
and there are people who are like,
"No, we need to be listening
to what the medical experts
"are telling us," and we're
on Team Medical Expert.
We're not medical experts,
but we're on Team We
Believe the Medical Experts,
the consensus of the
medical experts being that
we need to stay at home,
social distance and kind
of flatten the curve,
so this is our effort
to flatten the curve.
So we're gonna continue to
bring you what we can bring you,
it's just gonna be in a slightly
flattened-the-curve manner.
Yeah.
I just want,
I wanna hear the story that
I've heard like third-hand.
I want to hear it from your perspective,
because you haven't told me.
Christy was talking to Jessie
and I caught bits and pieces of,
she was shocked by someone
outside of her window.
I just didn't hear the full story,
I want to hear that from you,
right now.
Yeah, so our wives were
on a group video chat
with their close group of female friends.
Which they, I don't think
they had ever done that.
They've been on WeChat for years,
that's the thing that they
would talk to each other
and give themselves cute little
chat group names or whatnot.
They were well ahead of the curve of us
finally doing that with our friends.
But they never did video chats, so again,
it's just one example, like I said,
of a new normal, getting
used to this video chat,
group chat stuff, but anyway, go ahead.
But one of the things that has been
an unfortunate coincidence
is that it's been raining
like crazy in California.
I know.
Yeah, we gotta deal with this virus,
we gotta stay at home,
but that doesn't mean
you gotta stay in your house.
In fact, we've been
trying to take advantage
of being together as a family
and hiking and walking.
Barbara's gotten more
walks than, she's like,
"What are we doing, what is this?"
And by the way, park trails are now closed
as of yesterday, you can't go on a trail.
Well, I didn't tell you
this, but on Saturday,
and lemme tell you this
is whey they're closed,
because on Saturday,
Jessie and I were like,
hey, let's go up to the local trail head
to kinda get up in there, and
as soon as we pull in--
Get some trail head.
As soon as we pull into the place,
the cars are parked on the street,
so you know that all the
parking lots are overflowed.
And these trails are not wide.
They're narrow.
We drove right through
and drove right out,
'cause I was like, hey boys and girls,
that's not social distancing.
No.
I mean, just because you're
outside the virus isn't like,
"I'm outside, and so
therefore I can't move!"
If somebody coughs on
you or breaths on you
while you're on the trail and you, like,
you're heavin' and hoein'--
Huffin' and puffin'.
Heein' and hoein'?
I said heevin' and hovin'.
Heevin' and hovin'?
Yeah, before the governor
put in the stay-at-home provision
we had already decided that we were gonna,
both of our families, we had decided
we were going to hunker
down in our own homes
and send our employees
home and everything.
But it was the first day
that it hadn't rained,
and again, it was before
that ordinance was in place
and I said, "We can
just go on some trails."
And then we were on
the trail and there was
about as many people as normal,
but then, yeah, the huffin' and puffin.
Like, people would come down the trail
and I would stand to
the side and face away,
but I was self-conscious because,
again, this is pretty early.
A lot of people I think
were just on the trail
because it's part of their normal lives
just to go on this trail
and run up and down it or take their dog,
or if they're an old
person with the two sticks.
Lots of those old people with two sticks
were still out there at that point.
Yeah.
So I would like, instead of just like,
what's it called when you
pull back and you're--
That's a heave.
Okay.
That's the heave of the heave 'n huff.
Now I think that's acceptable.
'Course, you can't go on trails.
But then I would turn and I would act like
I was taking in the view, you know, like,
"It's beautiful out here," but
just to turn away from people
who were huffin' and
puffin' and goin' by me.
Well, what I've been doing,
I haven't been on a trail yet
and apparently am not
ever going to be again,
or not anytime soon.
Don't be so bleak, man.
We've been walking
around the neighborhood,
and we've seen people coming.
You know me, I can hold
my breath for a long time,
so when they get about 25, 30 steps away
I just hold my breath and then I go by
and then I release.
You start turnin' blue?
What if they stop and talk to you?
You're like .
I just give a head nod.
Mm-hmm.
Actually, I can talk and not breath in.
Yep, how you doin', I
haven't taken a breath yet.
Yep, I'm still breathin' out.
As long as there's air that's goin' out.
You know what, I can breathe in,
I can breathe and not talk, too.
You don't have to breathe in to talk.
I'm not breathing at all.
You actually don't even
have to change the way that you talk.
I don't know why we're doing that.
No, hold on, take a deep breath.
And then if I just talk,
no, I'm breathing out.
You gotta breathe out to talk.
But talking is breathing out.
Well I--
And then you do this.
It lets you talk like this--
You don't want to do that
'cause then you're suckin'
in other people's virus.
Yeah, I'm just using that as example.
Yeah, but you can't breathe back in
so it's just breathing out but you never
take a breath back in, so
whenever you stop talking
you're holding your breath
again and that is not
absolutely normal.
Right.
Anyway.
But where I was going with that
was I haven't had an opportunity
to go outside very much
because it's been raining so much.
I think this is our
last week of crazy rain
and then it's gonna get back
to more like Southern California.
But there was a moment of sunshine.
It wasn't very warm,
I mean for California,
it was like 55 degress,
which we're still like,
"Oh, that's a jacket."
It's like a blizzard to me.
But because the sun
came out I went outside
and actually took my shirt
off, got down just to my pants
and took my meditation cushion out there
and started doin' some
yoga, I did some meditation,
I mean I just became an
amateur guru out there
on my basketball area out here.
Amateur guru is not a thing.
Those words cancel each other out.
That's why I said amateur.
Wannabe guru, I think.
Wannabe guru.
Sure.
Nah, I don't think you're a wannabe guru.
And I think at this point, just sidebar,
my air conditioner, heater came on.
There's gonna be a lotta
noise in this podcast,
just get over it.
No one cares.
I'm not gonna apologize for it again.
Everybody was over it.
I was out there, first of all
I was just enjoying myself
just beyond words, and you know
I've gotten really flexible.
Have you seen how flexible I am now?
No.
I know I've been moving
around like a real old man
in all our vlogs, it's because of my knee,
but my knee is basically healed.
It took almost two months
for my knee to get healed.
So I'm kinda back to my spry self now.
Okay, yeah.
Just in time to do nothing.
Yeah, exactly.
Just in time to stay at home.
But I was doing all kinds of,
I was going on the internet,
looking at moves, doin' em.
But then I just started to
kinda walk around out there
and just take in the sun,
and then I realized that,
oh, I just walked up
to the window to the guest bedroom,
which is where Jessie is
currently on her ladies' chat.
Ah!
So what was, she hasn't told
me about this, by the way.
She told Christy that
she saw someone walk by and she thought
it was a shirtless
vagrant, like her emotional
and knee-jerk reaction was fear.
Yeah.
She was deeply afraid
because her husband
walked past the window,
and then it took her a couple of beats
and then she was like,
"Wait, that was my husband."
What have you done, man?
I mean, like--
Well, I will say--
You're gallivantin' around your house
and you're puttin' your
own family in fear.
Well, the other day--
This means something.
The other day, I was walking
through the neighborhood,
just by myself--
Shirtless?
No, but I didn't look well-kept.
No, no you don't.
Right.
And I had on a hoodie and
some un-matching sweatpants.
And like hiking shoes.
Okay.
'Cause it was the day we thought
we were gonna go to the trail.
Yeah.
And I know what my hair, listen.
I've seen the comments,
I've seen all the people
requesting beard or hair trims.
At this point it's
definitely not gonna happen.
I feel like I've been preparing
for this moment all my life
to look like this during this pandemic.
You were ahead of the curve.
But I was walking through the neighborhood
and I started realizing that
it could easily be perceived
that a homeless man
has left some urban area and is now
up into the neighborhoods
looking for a place to bed down.
His territory has expanded.
And I got a little paranoid.
Oh, you got paranoid.
And then all of a sudden,
at the height of my paranoia
I hear whoop whoop,
you know, like when the cops
do that thing where they
make that little noise.
Oh, sure!
They chirp it up.
A cop chirped you?
I turn around and there's a
cop like flying towards me.
What?
With his lights on
and the siren, and he's
chirpin', he's whoop whoop,
woop-woop-woop-woop-woop-woop
bwoop-bwoop-bwoop,
almost like a record
scratch with the chirp.
And I'm like, somebody has called and said
that there's a vagrant walking
through the neighborhood.
It was probably your wife!
And the cop is coming after me,
but then he just goes right past me.
You shoulda just got down.
He went right past me.
Put your hands behind
your head or somethin'.
But I was thinking about
what I was gonna say.
I was like, "Nah, nah, I live here!"
And I was realizing that
no matter what I said
everything was gonna sound made up.
I haven't been cutting my
hair because of therapy.
It's a long story.
I was actually thinking about this today
that even if I made a decision to trim,
I'm not gonna cut my
own hair at this point.
Yeah, well, you could,
I'm not saying you could.
I'm not saying you couldn't,
I'm saying you should.
But just to check in on that,
I don't feel like I've,
I don't feel like I've
learned my lesson yet,
you know what I'm saying?
You know if you listen to that Ear Biscuit
there's a reason I'm growing it out.
I don't think I've learned
what I need to learn yet.
I've learned that a lot of people,
I've learned that it's polarizing,
that's what I've learned.
Well, I think also have learned to, like,
keep a shirt on whenever possible,
stay off the streets,
try to get your sweatsuit to match
if you're going out in public,
just do a little somethin'
for yourself, you know?
I actually have some
thoughts about self-care
in this environment I'll
get to a little bit later.
For right now, let's plug the store.
Okay.
Mythical.com, go there.
Yeah, thankfully we've still got one.
We're still selling stuff.
We just released a new I
Am a Mythical Beast tee,
so check that out.
Yeah, and actually
the proceeds, a portion of
the proceeds from the sale
of the Be Your Mythical Best and 3D tee
are going to Feeding America,
a nationwide network of 200 food banks
working to ensure our most
vulnerable populations
continue to have access to food.
Students who are out
of school, the elderly,
individuals whose jobs are
impacted and low-income families.
The Feeding America food bank network
is committed to serving communities
and people facing hunger in America
during the COVID-19 pandemic.
Find out what they are
doing and how you can help
at FeedingAmerica.org.
Did you memorize all that?
That's great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wasn't reading.
That was really great.
I've had a lotta time.
You're devoting all of this extra time
to memorization.
Right.
I mean,
that is an idea.
There's time, we can invest
in ourselves a little bit.
Rep your boys, help a good cause,
be your mythical best by
wearing the Mythical Best tee.
There's also the feel-good stuff.
Everybody wants to feel good in this time.
We're selling some stuff at Mythical.com
to help you feel good physically,
in your body.
Mythical dots com.
I always wanna say mythical dot store.
Dots com.
It redirects,
but Mythical.com.
I'd just really like to
process what's happened
over the last few weeks.
How, what have,
I'm curious what your experience has been
and I just figure we could
share our experiences,
because it's just been so surreal.
There's so many times when I'm like,
it's like a movie, you know?
This doesn't really happen.
I've noticed that that thought
has started to happen less and less,
but for the first week and a half or so,
every night when I'd lay down in the bed
it was just like, I'd take a breath,
that would be the main
thing that I would feel
is like, "Is this real?"
You know, it was just we were
gettin' pummeled with news,
every few minutes was
something was changing,
every one in every sector of society
was just scrambling to
figure out what to do
and having the entire
spectrum of reactions.
I think the one moment
that will stick with me is,
let's see, it was couple weeks ago
before things got really stringent here.
Again, we were trying to
be as safe as possible
and we were preparing
to send employees home.
This is Wednesday, a couple of weeks ago.
And then just getting
'em prepared, like hey,
Friday, get your stuff, don't come in.
And then I think the
announcement went out officially
that Sunday, so I'm not saying,
"Hey, we were ahead of the curve,"
but we were sending people home,
we were starting to process,
but I had not watched the news.
I had read the news and I
had read the bites of news,
but we were in a very busy time.
We were actually recording a lot of GMM,
and thank goodness we recorded as much
as we were able to record, to then have
fully-produced set-based episodes
that we could stretch out.
But I had not consumed
live television news,
'cause it's just not a part
of my life anymore, you know?
I just don't like the bickering,
it's nothing but stress
and it just ticks me off.
But I was like hey, we gotta do this,
so I turned it on, I think
this was like Wednesday
or Thursday night--
Hold on one second.
Is the laundry room door closed?
Yeah, I just closed it!
Oh, it didn't get any quieter.
It's okay, go ahead Link.
It's fine, for what it's worth,
I can't hear your laundry.
You can't hear it because
you're listening to a video
chat which is not gonna get it
but I guarantee you--
That mic's probably gonna--
And this, we shouldn't have started
running the washing
machine, but it's fine.
And by we, you mean...
I mean my beautiful wife.
Oh, gosh.
What did you say?
Go, go finish gettin' ready!
What did you just say
about your beautiful wife?
Nothing.
Okay.
Yeah, you don't watch news.
I mean, I watch the news--
I knew that about you.
I've known that about you for many years
when we would get to work and I'd be like,
so did you hear about so-and-so?
But that makes it--
You know what?
I changed that!
That recently did change
because you got like an app--
No, not recently!
Over the past year, every
day I will read the headlines
on my phone, I will read the headlines!
But I'm not gonna turn on--
Hold on, hold on.
When you've been friends with
somebody for over 35 years,
recently is in the past
year, just so you--
Okay, well, that's not
what recently sounds like
to everybody else.
Just so you know.
So I turned on the news and it was,
it's a different experience
watching television news
than reading about it.
That's when it really hit me.
I mean, the newscaster
looked straight down the lens
and said, "We need to
come to grips with this.
"You need to come to grips with this.
"This is the new normal
for the foreseeable future.
"We're used to getting what we want,
"when we want it, and that's not
"going to be the case."
Jade, chill out.
I think she's gettin' worked up
'cause she thinks I'm getting worked up
because I'm channeling
my inner newscaster.
What are you barkin' at?
Do you hear Rhett's laundry?
It's okay.
And I gathered the kids around
'cause Christy and I were watching it,
and I said, "You know what, kids,
"I just want you to know
this is a huge deal.
"We're gonna be as safe as possible."
I gave them reassurance,
but then I also said,
"This is something that
you're gonna remember
"for the rest of your life."
Hey, am I gonna have to send you away?
And you know what I mean by that.
I just mean go in another room
and sit on another comfy couch.
The last time I remember
hanging on the words
of a newscaster was 9/11,
and I think it was the
governor of New York,
it may have been thrown
around by a bunch of people
that this is this generation's 9/11
in the sense that my experience,
all of the questions, all
of the fear that came up,
all of the,
just not knowing how to process it
and looking for someone
or the people who can
help make sense of it
to give reassurance that there's a plan,
that we're gonna be okay.
And I distinctly remember
that morning of 9/11,
just hanging on every
word of the newscasters,
and everyone was trying to figure it out
on live television, you know?
Mm-hmm.
And again, this was
more drawn-out than that
and it's different in a bunch of ways,
but there was a kindred experience
that then I tried to convey to the kids.
I just ended up saying,
"You're gonna remember this
the rest of your lives.
"Having to hunker down in our homes,"
I didn't make it that
bleak and doom-and-gloom.
As scared as I was, I didn't
wanna dump all of that on them
so I didn't do it.
Well, the interesting thing, you know,
I would say two things.
I come from a slightly
different place with this.
One,
my talk about the apocalypse--
Uh-huh.
I often talk about it in,
you know, I'm joking,
I'm going into character
and I'm just kinda BS-ing.
But that comes from a
place of actual concern
that, you know,
all our systems are so fragile.
We're seeing that right
now, we're seeing that
we were a lot more
vulnerable in a lot more ways
than anybody, well, I'm
gonna say than anybody knew,
but actually there's a lot of people
who've been saying for years, you know?
Again, I think people
who aren't in America
might be a little bit perplexed
as to what they hear
coming out of the U.S.
and they see on Twitter
and they see on the news,
it's like--
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Why is there this very bifurcated reaction
to what's happening, and
why does it seem like
people of a particular
political persuasion
seem to think a certain way about a virus?
I think that's probably rather perplexing
to people from other places in the world.
And there's a lotta reasons
that go behind that.
But I think that, interestingly,
we have seen a lot of people saying,
"Hey, guys, listen, this
is going to happen."
You see a lot of people saying like,
"Nobody could have been
prepared for this."
Well actually, there's
some excellent books
that have been written about
this that basically said
that this was completely
and totally inevitable,
unavoidable, predictable.
They've been telling us for years that
given how global our society is now
and how quickly people travel
and how easy it is for a virus to jump
from an animal to a person
and there being no immunity, anyway,
we kinda knew that this was gonna happen.
So I think I kinda had
in the many different
end-time scenarios that when you watch
"Doomsday Preppers" and that kinda thing.
And again, I don't think that,
we're not in an apocalyptic
situation by any means.
This is not the end of culture or humanity
or anything, this just a difficult thing
that is affecting everybody
and we have to kind of
come together and overcome
and we will overcome.
It's just a matter of
how long will it take?
But you're the type of person
that was familiar with the world
of the world going into crisis because
you have an interest in it
because there's somethin',
because of your personality
type there's something
within you that made you read about it,
but then there's a
second step that's like,
when you would read about these things
you would process them in a way
that led to personal application.
I think it was the GMM
episode where you went through
all the apocalypse bunker
stuff that you had bought,
and you took me through it,
and then you also bought
stuff for me, right?
Which hopefully you still have.
I still have, I haven't
had to dig into it yet
but I feel better knowing I have it,
so thank you once again.
But yeah, I think we
represent two different
personality types that, like,
and I think mines a little bit different,
but go ahead.
So yeah, this was something
that wasn't a surprise
to me, right?
Mm-hmm.
But the second thing was
we have the news on all the time.
It's kind of like,
we've got the news on
in the house at night
a couple, three times a
week, I think our kids,
our kids get very tired
of hearing me and Jessie
talk about the news.
Whereas with Lando, when I sat him down
and we were watching the news that night
it was the first time we
had ever watched the news
as a family, and the newscaster
was interviewing somebody
and they were getting
into it, like they do.
They were trying to cut each other off
and one guy wanted to
say what he wanted to say
instead of answer the question.
And Lando turned to me and said,
"Are they angry with each other?
"Are they fighting?" and I was like, yeah,
that's what happens on the
news, which was news to him.
Again, that's not my vibe, man.
I gotta watch the Australian news.
I think that's one of
the interesting elements
of this thing is that
because the whole world of news,
online, print and cable news,
everything is driven by ad revenue, right?
So for years we've gotten into this place
where it seems like every time
you come back from a break
on a cable news program,
breaking news, right?
And I think when things
actually become breaking news,
like they have right now,
when people actually need to know,
like it's a potential
life or death situation
whether or not they get this information,
I think people have maybe
become a little bit numb to
like, "Oh yeah, you guys are
panicking about something."
I think that's one of the
things that's happening
in our country, a lot
of people who are like,
"They're always talking
about the latest crisis.
"They're always talking about
how things are falling apart,
"but does it ever really happen?"
So I think that people
are skeptical of that.
You've even got the Nat Geo shows, like,
"The seven ways that the world will end
"and let's spend 60 minutes
on each one," you know?
And that's just not the type
of stuff I like to watch.
You like to watch that type of stuff.
Because I don't want,
I would rather think, and
on a subconscious level
it's been easy for me to think,
scientists or experts
in whatever field it is,
they have to be alarmists
in order to be heard.
You've gotta be your own hype man
if you want anybody to listen to you.
And it was a convenient
position subconsciously
for me to settle into, but I will say
turning on the news and
experiencing the breaking news
for the first time, because
I was out of that world,
I woke up.
I was texting you that night.
I was like, what does
this mean for our friends,
our families, for our company
in terms of action we need to take.
You were already talking about that,
so I felt like I kinda got on board.
And then there's people who are still,
it's had to sink in for
everyone in their own time
and that's the difficulty,
because in the meantime
this virus is movin' around.
But I think I did get on board
and I think you were like,
was there any part of you that was like,
I'll call it a morbid excitement.
Like yes, this is,
I don't want to frame you here,
maybe that's a nasty question.
Well,
I think that,
actually, I think it's
helpful sometimes because,
I'll talk in a second about
what I'm actually fearful of
and what I'm anxious about,
how I've been dealing
with that personally.
But to me, I find it helpful
when I'm going through
something that would
otherwise be fear-inducing
to kind of think about,
to think about being
in the midst of a story
that has a happy ending, right?
To think about what role you're playing in
this larger adventure of humanity
kind of coming together
and overcoming this thing.
So there is,
and I don't wanna talk about it now
'cause I think there's
a whole other podcast
in talking about why this
could ultimately be good
for humanity, experiencing
a crisis like this.
We could talk about all the things
that might change for the better.
I know you've been watching
"Lord of the Rings"
as well, right?
That's right, yeah.
So as a family, everybody in the family's
already seen the movies,
but it's been a while
and so far we've just watched
"Fellowship of the Ring"
and "The Two Towers," we haven't watched
"Return of the King" yet.
But you had to be thinking
the same thing I was thinking
multiple times during...
This could be my rec,
but I have another rec,
but I'll make a mid-podcast rec
of watching "The Lord
of the Rings" because
first of all, like you said,
you remember how much better
it is than "The Hobbit," right?
"The Hobbit" was a great book,
but the translation to three
movies, it just didn't,
"The Lord of the Rings" is,
it's my favorite trilogy, okay?
That I'm on, this is my favorite trilogy.
When I was watching it, I was like,
this is better than "Star Wars."
And Lily still wanted to fight me--
You know I've always thought that.
I know you've always thought that
but I had forgotten, it was
nice to get back into it.
But yeah, it was--
I don't weep while watching "Star Wars."
There's so many moments of
just pure joy and sadness.
Anyway.
Yeah.
But there's these things that
Frodo, and Sam especially,
and Gandalf, they kinda say to each other
that are these epic inspirational phrases,
there's these conversations that they have
where they start realizing, in fact,
is it at the end of "The
Fellowship of the Ring"
or is it "The Two Towers" where,
I think it's in "Two Towers"
where Sam starts talking about
are they gonna tell stories about us?
You know?
I think that might be the
end of the first movie.
Yeah, but it's like, are
we gonna be the heroes
in the story, and I'm not--
Right.
I like to think about
situations like this,
not like how am I gonna be a hero,
but how are we as a species
going to overcome this
and what's the story
that we're gonna tell?
And I hope the story that we tell
isn't that we started
not trusting one another
and we just were completely polarized.
This is an opportunity to come together.
Again, I so think it
requires people to actually
sorta digest what the real threat is,
and I think that even by the
time this podcast comes out,
that many more people will be like,
"Oh, okay, this is serious."
So I do think there's a part of me--
I find myself gleaning lots of hope
from watching the movies.
Yeah.
It's like the hope that
drove Sam and Frodo
on their journey and
that drove everyone else
to do whatever they could,
even when they couldn't
help Frodo directly anymore
they could help out their friends.
They could help out those
that they were with.
Yeah.
Or say, okay, we can't go after them
but we can go after Merry
and Pippin, you know?
And it hit me at such a point
where I really needed it.
I don't think I've ever
gleaned so much hope
from watching a movie
that applied directly to,
it just kind of fueled my ability
to get up the next day
and be positive.
I think that's good for us.
Yeah.
That's the kind of stuff that,
those are the kind of
challenges that we need to face,
that we need to come together and face.
Specifically, the way that I've kind of
been responding to it
in terms of how this,
the virus kind of taps
into my hypochondria--
Okay.
Has been interesting.
Even though I know from
a statistical standpoint
the majority of people who get it
won't even know they have it,
and then on top of that
a larger majority of people who get it
will not require hospitalization.
And then within our age group,
with no underlying health conditions,
again, statistically, we're
probably gonna be okay
even if we contract this thing, right?
But you hear those stories, right?
I think a lot of the
stories that we're hearing,
and I think that these
are getting more attention
because they're surprising, it's like,
"Oh, 31-year-old Olympic
gold medalist swimmer
"just dealt with this for two weeks
"and is still feeling the effects,"
or, "34-year-old dude in
L.A. dies from COVID-19."
So there's a part of me that, I mean,
of course I'm thinking about my parents
who are in the higher-risk group--
Yeah.
Your parents, you know,
we know a lot of people who
are in higher-risk groups--
And I got my, both of my grandmothers.
Yeah, you've still got grandparents
who are alive in their 90s.
Yeah.
So thinking about them,
but then I start thinking,
"Oh, I think I have,
"do I have a dry cough?"
You know, I'll start thinking,
"Do my lungs feel funny?"
Like that's how my hypochondria
kind of manifests itself
and I start thinking that,
"Have I contracted this?
"Am I gonna be one of the statistics?"
So I kinda get on a little
bit of a fear loop--
Spiral.
Doing that.
And it hasn't helped
that I've also, I think,
now I already knew that I was
slightly allergic to dogs.
Like when I got my allergy
test a couple years ago
the only thing that came
up was a slight allergy
to dogs and cats,
but it was like a two
out of five or something.
But COVID-19 does not give you
an allergic reaction to dogs.
Right, but because I am now
at home with Barbara a lot,
spending a lot of time with Barbara,
it's like I've had this
drainage and sore throat
that's been going on like two weeks now,
and I'm reasonably certain it's just--
That it's COVID-19.
That's what I thought,
even though those are not really symptoms
of COVID-19 for most people.
So up until like yesterday when it hit me,
I was like, "Oh, this might
be because me and Barbara
"are having so much quality time,"
which I've really enjoyed all
my quality time with Barbara.
I don't know what I'm gonna do about that.
I might have to get a
better allergy medication.
But anyway--
You could shave her bald.
I thought you were gonna
say something else,
and then I was gonna say
that she's a female dog.
Bald.
You know where the allergens come from,
the come from the scrotum of the dog.
The hair on the scrotum.
But my wife has the exact opposite issue,
and she thinks that she's
going to give it to someone,
right?
Okay.
So I'm worried about getting it,
she's worrying about giving it.
Well that should make
you feel better, right?
That she's not gonna give it to you.
Well, I don't think she's worried about--
Is she wearin' a mask everywhere?
No, no.
Okay.
But as you know, I do have masks
because that was one of the things
that I had already bought many years ago.
I don't have many, I have like
a couple of packages of 'em,
because you don't need 'em
unless you're sick, technically.
We were gonna have just
a couple for ourselves.
If you have an N95 mask it
can offer some protection
if it's sealed correctly,
which is pretty hard
to do with a beard like this.
Like if you're gonna
go into a grocery store
and you want to be extra safe
it's not gonna hurt to wear a mask.
But Jessie's like, "Hey,
we need to take these masks
"to the hospital," so
she's already talking
to this person on Twitter,
this is like three, four days ago.
And again, this is like two weeks out
from when you're gonna see this episode.
But in Santa Monica there was an ER doctor
who was already saying,
"We're running out of masks.
"I will drive anywhere
in L.A. to pick them up,
"I don't care how many you have,"
and so she was talking to
this person on Twitter.
But at the time she
kinda had a sore throat
and she was like, "I
just wanna let you know,
"full disclosure, I have a sore throat,"
and the woman was like,
okay, wait 14 days.
Anyway, we're probably gonna
give our masks to a hospital,
as you should if you have some
if you're one of the people that,
like me, had some ahead of time.
I think for me it's, you know,
I don't obsess about if I have it or not.
I feel like for over a week now already
we've been isolated, we've
been very strict about it,
so with every day I'm
gaining more confidence
that we're not carrying it,
and we're doing everything in our power
to protect ourselves and
other people at the same time.
So for me it's more about
channeling my energies into
a routine, really routine.
Things that I know like I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna fill my day with things,
I'm gonna occupy myself.
As we've been developing
what our work plan is,
that's certainly helped,
but before we really got on top of that
there were a few days there
where it was just like
a lotta cleaning, you know?
Yesterday I went in, I
always go into my shower
and as I said in the You're
Not Showering Properly
GMM episode or whatever it's titled,
we change the titles so much.
I will clean the drain of the shower
because there's so much freakin'
hair that gets in there.
I don't know how my wife has any
on her head anymore, honestly.
My shower won't drain unless
I clean the hair out of it,
and I'm blaming it all on her
because she's not currently here.
Her and Lily just walked out
to take a walk or somethin'.
But the way my shower works,
it's like this fancy,
long, heavy strip of tile
that's like a, it's like a one-inch tall,
two-inch wide,
four-inch deep, like slab,
that you have to pull
out, because it looks,
it looks fancy, right,
you can't see the drain
and then the water drains all in it.
And when you pull out this
big freakin' rectangular slab
there's one little drain at the end,
just one silver dollar drain
with like a thing on it.
But that whole trough is plastic,
and it fills up with soap gunk.
And so here I am for the first time ever,
not just cleaning the
hair out of the drain
but I'm gettin' down on all fours
and I'm spraying stuff down,
I'm grabbin' a hand towel
and I'm cleaning out the
trough of this thing.
Felt good.
Didn't feel necessary
but it felt very good.
Even though I totally destroyed
my hand towel with bleach.
It's like a pink mosaic now.
That's nice.
Not really, it's pretty ugly.
We've been doing a lot of cleaning,
and getting to things that over time,
like the area next to my
bed, like my bedside table
I had stacked books and
electronic equipment
and stuff and it just slowly,
my wife calls it my corner.
She's like, "When are you
gonna clean your corner?"
You have one at the office too.
And I'm like, "Well, when I have time."
'Cause it's not that important,
it's not important to clean the corner.
Well, the corner is cleaned.
The corner is very clean right now,
you could sit in my corner--
Did you take a before and after photo?
No, I don't do that kind of thing.
I don't need to congratulate
myself with pictures.
Uh, you know what?
I'm not gonna take that
because it's your loss
that you don't want to stop and celebrate
your own accomplishments.
I don't wanna become addicted to it.
Of course that doesn't happen.
Who's addicted to
cleaning and organization?
Exactly.
Who finds themselves trapped
by their own processes?
Right.
No one.
The think that I've been thinking,
so we have been,
from a both personal and
professional standpoint,
this has shaken things up,
changed things around, right?
Completely, really.
My heart goes out to the many people
whose businesses just completely
stopped because of this.
And I understand that
that's one of the big
national debates happening right now.
And we can talk a little
bit more about this
maybe in a subsequent podcast, about like
weighing the value of the economy
versus the number of deaths, which to me
seems like sort of a weird thing to weigh.
But I understand that
a complete depression,
economic depression, will
harm people and make people,
it will lead to, ultimately,
more death in some ways.
So it is a factor and I'm
sensitive to the people who,
they don't have any way
to make money right now.
We're in a position where
we can still bring content
to people even if it's
slightly altered like this,
but assuming that the ad
market is still going to be
somewhat, is gonna to exist on some level.
We still are in a service business,
we're offering a service that we think
is helpful at this time,
and so we're committed to doing it,
but thankfully we're in a
position where we can do that
and keep our employees employed
and that kind of thing.
And not everybody's in that position,
so we recognize that we're
in a privileged position
to do that, but that is our mentality.
Yeah, I think the conversations
we've been having,
the word opportunity comes up a lot.
And when we talk to our team we're trying
to convey that to them as well that,
let's look at, let's
be as smart as we can,
let's be as safe as we can,
and then within that context
let's look at the things
that we can actually do, the
things that we have control of,
and let's look for as many
opportunities that this
extremely challenging and
scary situation grants us.
Because we can still make videos,
it's an opportunity for us to do that.
I think the main opportunities are not
to capitalize on anything,
I mean opportunity
in the sense of service.
An opportunity to serve
our immediate families
because we're spending
so much time together.
Our friends and loved ones
via phone calls and chats.
Serving our Mythical team,
some of which we can give work to,
others don't have as much to do from home
because of the nature of what
they were doing at Mythical,
there's just little
for them to do at home.
But givin' them an assurance that, hey,
we're gonna keep putting out content
in the most creative way we can
in order to continue to support
all of our team and to
keep 'em on the payroll,
just to be blunt about it.
But also to create content as a way to,
an opportunity to serve
all the Mythical Beasts, to serve you.
Because, I mean, we're
continuously blown away
with the opportunity we have
to make things that connect with you.
We come back to it a lot on this podcast,
that it's an amazing
privilege to be able to create
something that's a source
of light in your life
and when we all, everybody
on Earth is experiencing
some level of shadow
being cast by this virus
over their lives, some of them it feels
like a complete eclipses, and
if they're a Mythical Beast
and we can give 'em 15 minutes,
25 minutes with Good Mythical
MORE every single weekday,
if we can give 'em a vlog,
if we can give 'em these conversations,
it's a privilege to be able to do that.
And it's exciting to
know that we can do it.
It's very engaging for me to say,
you know what, I can
make this not just for,
it's not about the business,
it's not about the money
except in supporting our team
and our families--
And we've talked about this before--
But it's about supporting
the Mythical Beasts, too.
You know, one of the things that we
have just realized over the years is that
we never set out to do
anything except create, right?
Even years ago, we just were like, okay,
we're just gonna make videos,
oh, there's an audience here,
and then people started talking about
the effect that the regular content
coming into their homes had on people,
helping people get through things.
I think for many years I always
felt really self-conscious
and kinda uneasy about
that, because I was like,
"Well, that's not what we're trying to do.
"We're just trying to make you laugh,"
but eventually I kinda
just accepted the reality
that making people laugh is therapeutic,
it's good, it's like
you got to embrace that.
This is helpful, and I think that
in a moment like this
when you can't do anything
except consume content, for some people
you're in a situation where it's like,
okay, I can clean, I can work out,
I can take a hike, I can make myself food.
But really a lot of us are
just consuming content,
reading books, listening to podcasts,
watching internet videos, watching movies.
And those are,
yeah, it's an opportunity,
and it's an opportunity
that we take very seriously,
so we're completely committed,
just like Link said,
we're completely committed
to continuing to bring you
the content that we
have always brought you.
It's gonna look a little
bit different, of course,
and we'll be talking about how
that's gonna affect GMM
and some other things,
and hopefully this is not
too long of a period of time
and we'll get back to a
somewhat normal schedule soon.
But our intention is that we recognize
that this is something
that people kinda count on,
especially during this time, and we wanna,
not just for the sake of
our business and our company
kinda remaining buoyant,
but also to serve you guys.
Kinda the additional
thing I've been thinking
is, again, and I'm trying
to evaluate whether or not
what part of this comes
from a healthy place
and what part comes from my sort of,
my own personal struggles with being
so performance-based,
kinda having that mindset
of always wanting to do-do-do
and finding my self-worth in what I do.
I've seen this virus,
I mean a lot of people
are taking advantage of this time
to not only do things for people,
but to do things that are super-cool
and get them noticed, right?
And sometimes I start thinking like,
okay, all right, we've
got GMM, that's great,
but we've always had that.
We've got your Biscuits, that's great,
We've got the Mythical Kitchen stuff
that we recently added to the mix,
all this stuff.
But I start feeling this
pressure to be like,
"But what else could we do?" you know?
And I think that some of that could be,
and I also feel like from
a personal standpoint,
which is like, oh, you've got
all this time on your hands.
Well you know what, you should
really figure yourself out.
This is an opportunity
to really accelerate
that work you've been doing in therapy
and you need to,
this is when you really need to sit down
and figure out what your
values are and your goals
and all this stuff and the
things that you keep putting off,
kinda like getting your mind
straight about this stuff.
So I've felt sort of
this intense pressure,
I've actually been overwhelmed
by it a couple of times,
and I've felt myself waking
up in the middle of the night
thinking about, "What am I gonna do?
"What are we gonna do?"
Uh-huh.
"What are we gonna do to
take advantage of this?"
Not in a slimy
get-more-attention kinda way,
but it's just like, you know,
being in this sort of
desperate, desperate times
but being in a position where
we can bring people stuff,
feeling this pressure to be like,
what else could we do and
what else could I do to
deal with myself and all
the problems that I have?
Yeah, I mean, for me,
recording this podcast is a relief for me
because I now know that we're wrapping up
and we actually got one in the
can and were able to do it.
We're gonna record the
first Good Mythical Morning
split-screen ever in a few
hours, I'll feel much better.
But yesterday I was completely overwhelmed
setting up all the technical
aspects and I just,
I felt very buried so I
didn't have the margin
to think that much about those things
but I definitely understand.
I think the,
I wanted to read a quote form an article
that I think speaks directly to this,
and also hopefully can
serve as encouragement
to you listening, too.
I was reading a Washington Post article
which came across Twitter,
and in that article which,
I'm sorry, I can't
remember what it's called,
but there's a rabbi,
Rabbi Yosef, was quoted
from his Facebook page
where he had written
to his L.A. congregation, but then
it was put in the Washington Post article
and had an impact on me
in terms of my mindset.
He said: Every hand that we don't shake
must become a phone call that we place.
Every embrace that we avoid
must become a verbal expression
of warmth and concern.
Every inch and every foot
that we physically place
between ourselves and
another must become a thought
as to how we might help that
other should the need arise.
So yeah, I think that
this morning, you know,
in an effort to keep my routine going
and to start my day with some sanity,
I've been trying to do my
workouts in the garage.
And this morning I was halfway through it
and this Golden Retriever
just runs up into my garage.
And then it ran back,
I petted the Golden
Retriever, it ran back out
and then this woman who's
a neighbor that I see
but never talk to is walking
by, and I take the earbud out
and we had a conversation, and it was,
"How are you doing?"
From 10 feet away.
Yeah, from 10 feet away, and I was like,
"Oh, maybe I shouldn't
have touched her dog."
I'd only pet it once but
I'm not gonna sit here
and love up on the dog.
But we had a,
it was a friendly
conversation, it was short,
but there was an undertone of
care that I gave and received
that was extremely powerful, that I never,
and it was simple, it was,
"This is so surreal, isn't it?
"Do you have everything you need?
"It's actually a beautiful morning,"
and then that was it, you know?
But there was a connection that otherwise
would never have been made.
And I drew strength from giving that care
and also receiving it.
It doesn't have to be the big things,
it can be those small
interactions, you know?
And I think about all the
opportunities that I have
within my own home with my family.
The amount of time that
we're spending together
is utterly unprecedented,
and there's a lotta pitfalls
associated with that.
I'm sure we'll get into all that later.
We need to wrap up for
the sake of uploading
this huge freakin' file.
But I just wanted to
leave it at that quote.
Yeah, I think, you know,
we're gonna see, I think we are seeing
the best and the worst
in people right now.
There are people who are
thinking about themselves.
People hoarding, people buying up things,
people price-gouging.
But I think that the majority of people
are thinking about their fellow person.
I have hope that in the end
that this is gonna bring us together,
even though we are, especially
in this country, divided.
Again, like I said, even about
our perspective on a virus.
A virus has no political affiliation.
The virus doesn't care about
whether you're in a red state
or a blue state, but
still, for some reason
we just, we're so
polarized in this country
that we filter everything through that.
We can't hear a piece of news
without filtering it through the source.
But I think that this is,
it's an unprecedented situation,
but it's an unprecedented opportunity
to think about what you can do
for your fellow human.
I would say to love
yourself and to love others.
Yeah.
Okay, I think this went okay.
I think it went well.
You got a rec, though?
Yeah, I do.
I've been telling you about this,
you haven't responded
to me about this yet.
Oh, I know what you're gonna say.
Now first of all, I will say
you do need to watch "Lord
of the Rings," do that.
That's clear.
You gotta watch "Tiger King" on Netflix.
Everyone's been talkin' about this.
Many of you have probably
already watched it,
you've heard about
people talkin' about it.
And it's not for everybody,
let me just say that.
It's not for everybody.
It's a documentary.
It's a docu-series--
I didn't know that.
About a,
not just, one guy, the "Tiger King",
is just a dude who
raises tigers, you know?
And like a sketchy situation,
like the whole home zoo
and exotic animals and that kind of thing.
But it's the world of that guy
and then other people like him,
but it's also kind of a murder
mystery, and it's all real.
I watched the first episode last night
because you told me to watch
it and I was laughing out loud.
The first episode, real
fresh to me, amazing.
There were some hilarious edits.
Getting to know him as a character,
and then it takes some turns
and it's like, it's serious.
But I've never laughed so hard--
You wait for episode two.
Like everything that you thought,
like they go a level deeper
and you're like, "No.
"No, no, no, no, no, that can't be true."
Yeah, they keep peelin,
it's like an onion.
They keep peeling back
layers, I'm like, "What?"
The onion goes down like four
more layers on episode two.
You gotta watch it,
"Tiger King".
You gotta watch it.
On Netflix, for me, the
thing that I was thinking
when I was watching it is I was like,
"Man, we need to find a story like this,"
it was just inspirational
for me to think about--
It was like over decades.
Yeah, I know.
I don't know if he was
just utilizing the footage
because the guy had a
cameraman follow him forever
and then somebody came
in and like, anyway.
They get into it a little better.
Yeah, I agree.
If you can't tell, I agree with the rec.
Okay, so we're gonna be doing this
for the foreseeable future from our homes.
Let us know what you thought
about this conversation
and how you're dealing with
all this, hashtag #EarBiscuits.
We'll be talking about it.
Hashtag #EarBiscuits.
We'll be speaking at you next week.
Love ya.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.